a family of eight lived in this box of the cleaner
some of them were born in it born on the road
along a highway there are more than a million home
we came to this family moving out the
land had played out on him he said
most of my - our young people with young children
we have another name for these people
heading west that's my most of them now
America the new world 300 years
ago this cry rang through Europe
to lift the hearts of the defeated
the French accuser but this today
a new world a new chance to live
Arizona 49ers will pass through
this country couldn't see how even
the Coyotes could live in it no water
but engineers came in not so long ago
we'll get more gold out of this country
they said than the 49ers ever dreamed
they went into the mountain built dams
and impounded great reservoirs of water